good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy tuesday
so here's a question for you what does
joe biden believe
what are his plans for our country well
it's hard to comprehend this but the
truth is we still don't know the answers
to those most basic questions we don't
somehow joe biden made it through an
entire presidential campaign
most of a year without telling us
a partisan press corps let him get away
with it
that may be the single most dishonest
thing that has ever happened in american
politics
if you're looking for election rigging
there you go
tens of millions of people voted for a
candidate
who wasn't real they voted for a ghost
with a white and smile
they had no idea who this man was they
had no idea
who they were voting for or what he
might do if he got elected
but at the urging of the media they
voted for him anyway
and so now the rest of us get to find
out what they voted for
joe biden has started to assemble his
cabinet so we're going to go by his
choices to let us know what we can
expect
and what is emerging so far as of
tonight looks a lot like the hr
department at a large left-wing
multinational
heaps of woke authoritarian social
policy
mixed with a corporatist economic agenda
so the rest of us will get stern
lectures about our moral failings those
never end
while a small group of highly connected
people will get even richer
does that sound familiar to you if jeff
bezos and the google guys took over the
entire us government
and effectively they have this is what
it would look like
steve roshetti is the archetype for the
new biden aides
he's now one of joe biden's closest
advisors rashetti has spent years as a
lobbyist he's representing companies
like general motors att glaxosmithkline
eli lilly nextel novartis pfizer all the
big
all the big pharma companies richetti is
one of the people who helped
lead the alignment of big business
squarely behind the joe biden for
president campaign
and he was the perfect man to do it
because he shares their goals
and their worldview particularly on the
question the central question of china
20 years ago steve roshetti was the
deputy chief of staff to bill clinton
and in that role he helped lead the
effort to allow china
into the world trade organization that
turned out to be
not a small thing at all his lobbying
worked
the result in the end was one of the
greatest disasters ever to befall this
country in peacetime
one study by the economic policy
institute and there were others but this
one found
that thanks to that decision to let
china into the wto
the united states lost nearly three and
a half million good paying jobs
and the effects of that have rippled
through the generations
if you're wondering why there's a
fentanyl epidemic in middle america
if you're wondering why the life
expectancy
for american-born middle class americans
is in decline that's a big part of the
reason
millions of men lost their jobs and an
entire society collapsed
if you live inward from the coasts
you've seen it firsthand
steve or shetty was one of the people
behind that not the only one
but one of the key people he wasn't
punished for it in fact he's been
promoted joe biden wants more of it
biden also wants less dissent from the
population
biden knows what we all know which is
that an armed society is an
independent society he's not for that
and that's why he's hired congressman
cedric richmond as a senior advisor
richmond plans to disarm
law-abiding americans not criminals
people who commit
gun crimes are now being led out of jail
but law-abiding americans people who've
done
nothing wrong who've tried in good faith
to protect themselves and their family
they will be punished that's not
speculation by the way richmond has said
so
on television here he is on cnn last
year
if it is a buy back then i'm all for it
uh if it's a mandatory buyback i think
they you may run into some complications
but
the thought of it does not offend me and
it sounds like something i could support
so gun control didn't play a large role
in our debates coming up to the election
there was almost no discussion about
issues for six months
but it's becoming clear that preventing
americans from defending themselves
and their families is a big part of the
biden agenda
and that's part of the reason that
campaign manager jennifer o'malley dylan
to be his
deputy chief of staff at a time when a
record number of americans have
purchased
legal firearms to protect themselves
from skyrocketing crime
dylan has called for this confiscation
of more than 10 million legally owned
firearms again we're not making that up
it's not propaganda
here she is saying it herself but a plan
that supports
bless you um mandatory buybacks of
weapons of war an assault weapon ban is
very very important and we need to have
it
but that only takes weapons of war off
the streets in the future
it does nothing for weapons of war that
are currently out there and i think
there's 15 or 16 million
i think there's 15 or 16 million she
doesn't know the number she doesn't know
anything imagine what she knows about
firearms or about anything else
probably about zero when does the bullet
come out of she doesn't know
but it doesn't matter she plans to seize
them anyway
mandatory buybacks are seizure taking
private property
by force not because the people who own
those firearms have done
anything wrong they haven't jennifer
o'malley dylan just doesn't think you
should be allowed to
have them so what's that going to look
like what's it going to look like
when the biden administration tries to
disarm law-abiding
americans apparently we'll find out
we do know the entire country could look
very different very soon
alejandra mayorkas will make certain of
that biden has chosen him to run the
department of homeland security
now the department of homeland security
if you're old enough you will remember
was created almost 20 years ago in the
wake of the 9 11 attacks and it had just
one purpose protect
the country americas has a different
plan for dhs though
he plans to use the agency to radically
increase the amount of immigration from
the third world
into america because america doesn't
have enough going on right now we just
don't have enough problems so we're
going to mix it up a little bit
in an interview a few years ago on pbs
marcus called for
amnesty legal amnesty for anyone who
arrived in the united states
illegally under the age of 31
regardless of how old they are now think
about that
how many people would that include well
probably tens of millions
watch so what else would you look for
perhaps a a greater population of
individuals who would qualify
in terms of their age so one of the
limitations on daca was
one had to be under the age of 31 at the
time of application
even though one might have been brought
to the united states as a two-year-old
decades ago ago and so really the
determinative factor should be
uh how old was one when one came to the
united states
as opposed to how old one is now but you
could see it being
exp you'd like to see it expanded i
would
yeah i would guys like that and barack
obama is a perfect example
are the opposite of donald trump no
matter what trump says he could be
reading the phone book
he could be reading the lyrics to the
birthday song and it always sounds
big loud jarring but people like that
the actual radicals people are saying
things that are completely
out of the mainstream and you can check
the polling that's not speculation
that view is not a majority view it's
the view of a tiny group of radicals
but people like that say those things in
the calmest tone like it's totally
natural of course yeah not a big deal
it is a big deal if marcus gets his way
this will be
a different country overnight with very
different
politics and of course different
politics are the entire point
so that's a snapshot of domestic policy
as it's shaping up
under the biden administration how about
foreign policy
well joe biden says he's nominating a
man called anthony blinken tony blinken
to be secretary of state it's the head
of our foreign policy
lincoln is the co-founder of a so-called
strategic consulting group known as west
tech advisors
we know that westeck has represented
silicon valley firms and pharma
companies
but because technically it's not a
lobbying operation we don't know that
much more west tech is not legally
required to disclose
where they're getting their money we do
believe eric schmidt of google
at least reportedly was a client of
westech and that tells you a lot
blinken himself has written op-eds for
the new york times he's been a global
affairs
analyst at cnn and that tells you a lot
like everyone else on that channel
blinken fell hard for the ludicrous
russia collusion line watch
every time the president tears down the
fbi
or mueller or any of our institutions
he's actually doing mr putin's bidding
it's exactly what putin was trying to do
in our elections that is so doubt
about the credibility and legitimacy of
our institutions the president's ongoing
collusion
uh with russia's plans is really
striking intentional or not
so when you criticize the fbi that's not
your first amendment right as an
american no you're quote
doing mr putin's bidding it's all part
of quote the president's ongoing
collusion with russia
now tony blinken is the best we produce
there's not a credential that he doesn't
have
he went to harvard unlike you
but as with so many people with those
credentials
he's not a genius and you can tell that
by his position on the invasion
of iraq here is blinken during the obama
administration
celebrating our occupation of that
country like it's been a roaring success
the wisdom of going to war in iraq is
something that is going to be debated
for years and i'll leave that debate to
the historians
but what's beyond debate and what news
coverage of iraq in my judgment
too often fails to acknowledge is that
iraq today is less violent
more democratic and more prosperous and
the united states more deeply engaged
there
than at any time in recent history
yeah a rock's in great shape good point
tony blinken
you seem like a pretty smart guy you
should be secretary of state
and so under joe biden he will be
not impressive but what does it all add
up to it's starting to look like the
opposite the mirror image of what donald
trump
ran on in 2016. policies that were so
popular trump got elected on them
despite having no background in politics
whatsoever coming completely from the
outside
and rattling people a little bit and he
still got elected
because those policies were popular and
they remain
popular but biden apparently is about to
give us the opposite
more giveaways to our chief global rival
the government of china
more pointless wars in the middle east
that no one outside washington
supports massive increases in illegal
immigration
along with a huge drop in american wages
that always
is the inevitable result of that when
you flood the low-end labor pool
the price of labor goes down that's
called supply and demand geniuses but
they don't care
and then of course the attendant chaos
and instability at home which they have
stoked for months now
fewer americans able to defend
themselves and their families
in the face of that chaos which they
caused
and above all and this is the defining
characteristic
so far more corporate control
over our lives this is the point
this is the theme let's hope we're wrong
but as of tonight it looks like
this is what we're staring down if you
believe the federal government
is powerful now in some cases too
powerful wait until it
fully aligns with big business
that appears to be happening the
question is how many people
knew they were voting for that when they
voted for this guy
probably not too many